en un hecho que el canciller mexicano
marcelo ebrard no dudó en calificar de
histórico se lanzó el entendimiento
bicentenario un mecanismo de cooperación
en materia de seguridad que marca una
nueva etapa en la relación de méxico y
eeuu se trata de la creación de
distintos grupos de trabajo enfocados a
reducir la violencia prevenir los
delitos transfronterizos perseguir a las
redes criminales abordar los temas
relativos a la defensa y marina así como
la conformación de un comité binacional
que vigilará el cumplimiento de estas
metas considerando la agenda propia de
cada país
el embajador estadounidense ken salazar
dijo que se trata de una verdadera
alianza basada en la confianza mutua y
en el respeto a la soberanía de cada
nación en cuanto al tráfico de armas
señaló que si bien es un tema de
responsabilidad compartida el gobierno
de joe biden reconoce que un flujo de
armas es de estados unidos hacia méxico
destacó también la acción inmediata
contra grupos de traficantes de personas
que han provocado muertes como la de más
de 50 migrantes
recientemente en el estado de chiapas
este lanzamiento del entendimiento
bicentenario se da en vísperas de la
celebración de los 200 años del inicio
de la relación bilateral al conmemorarse
en 2002